welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy who's a pain in the neck like a
vampire and this video are breaking down
fierce street part three
up top i just want to apologize for
missing part 2 last week
i had a bit of a bad spell over the
weekend
and just wanted to rest up so i took
some time off but we basically watched
the highly talked about massacre at camp
nightwing
playing out in all its gory it was
clearly based upon the 70s slasher
friday the 13th
and it set up seraphia's as the most
wicked witch of the west
or on the shady side we followed the
soul survivor christine and her sister
cindy as they chronicled what really
happened there
however 1666 reveals the truth and it
takes us on an even further time jump as
we go back to the air in question to see
things
through the eyes of sarah whereas the
first film was based on the slashes of
the 90s
and the last one the ones of the 70s
1666 is giving a lot of nods to films
like dead birds
the village and of course the seminal
horror the witch
this new setting really worked for me
and i think that out of the trilogy that
this was by far the strongest
they also bring several of the previous
cast members to play the god-fearing
villagers
who are of course the ancestors of those
that have been getting murdered
now whilst we initially believe that we
were simply seeing the origin story of
fears
things go far beyond that and we learn
not only of the settlement the union
but also who is behind everything sarah
falls in love with one of the other
villagers named hannah and the pair have
to live in secret because of the
prejudices at the time
dina of course relates to the character
quite a lot and we see
much in the same way that our friends
were blamed for carrying out the murders
that sarah eventually is too sarah's
father wants her to marry a man named
solomon good
who is the ancestor of nick a man we met
in 78 that would grow up to become the
sheriff of the town
we later learn exactly why he didn't
tell the truth about what happened at
the camp
and though it was thought that it was
simply because he wanted to be sheriff
it was all part of his power play now
unfortunately
sarah and hannah's secret gets out and
when a pastor known as cyrus miller
becomes a murderer that seemingly
possessed
suspicion turns on the pair the ladder
is caught and sarah goes to solomon for
help
which is where we discover that it was
he who was behind the entire thing
turns out that in their lust for power
the goods have been
evil this entire time and you can't get
mad at me for that pun
as it's a line in the actual movie
anyway i thought i'd explain the curse
in general before we get into the rest
of the film
and this thing that has plagued the
entire town started all the way back in
1666
with a widowed solomon suffering from
depression after losing his wife and
child
realizing that life wasn't all that it
was promised to be
he made a deal with the devil in order
to improve his circumstances
and in exchange for offering up one of
the town's folk to lucifer he was given
wealth and prosperity
the goods have passed down this
knowledge throughout the years and over
the centuries they've offered up people
from shadyside
in order to improve not only their lives
but sunnyvale as well
this idea of one town being better than
the other is even hinted at in their
names
as being sunny of course is more sought
after than the shade
and the idea of a veil of course can be
used to cover up the truth of what's
beneath it
solomon lived on the outskirts of the
union but through doing this he's pretty
much built up sunnyvale around him
and this is why we get the reveal of the
home at the end of the film which i'll
talk about later on
the name solomon likely comes from king
solomon and the goods have ruled over
the two towns for centuries and
centuries
now upon discovering this solomon cuts
off sarah's hand
and brings her before the village where
she is hanged all you had to do back
then was yell witch and everyone
believed it
and i'm glad that these days people
question what they're told
unless it's posted on facebook by
someone you went to school with
who failed science anyway moving on
sarah saves hannah by confessing that it
was her
but she says that she will haunt solomon
and his family forever
her friends bury her with a crown of
moss and this ends up becoming important
in the town as it not only appeared in
the cave during 78 as a way to lead some
of the survivors out
but it also helped to pass on certain
visions though her curse wasn't as
destructive as the goods
she is right in saying that she'll lead
to their downfall and this
very much plays into the ending the
curses sort of work together as one
and we learn that anytime someone
discovers sarah's curse by touching her
bones
that a member of the goods becomes aware
of this and they send their minions into
murder them before their secret is
revealed
now if you're enjoying the video so far
then i'd massively appreciate the thumbs
up
so make sure you smash it over the head
until it stops moving
and hit the subscribe to join my dark
dominion
anyway we cut back to the present and
part two of part three
but bear with me you know this is about
dina exposing the truth of what happened
whilst taking nick good down i love how
they actually hinted towards a lot of
things like this throughout the other
movies
and much in the same way that solomon
showed up to kill cyrus when he was
possessed
nick did the same thing in the first
episode during the murder of maya hawk
maya he maya who my haha
yeah i know i did that joke last time
but it's a good one yeah just let me
have me good ones
anyway dina and josh are discovered in
the woods by nick and they quickly
deduce that he's been working with the
devil once more
they steal his car and he sends the
undead killers after them
they come up with a plan and using the
last surviving members of the town it
seems
they trap the possessed killers inside
the mall they cover nick and dina's
blood and thus the killers go after him
instead
but he grabs christine during this dina
cuts herself to draw them to her once
more and this leads to nick
chasing dina through the tunnels under
it this of course mirrors the journey
that sarah went on whilst trying to
escape solomon earlier in the movie
and again it's like poetry they rhyme i
get sick of saying that sometimes but
sometimes
i'm really proud of myself like this one
now down here he discovers the literal
scab that has been growing in the depths
of the town
and here a possessed sam catches her
however dina breaks through for a second
and manages to free her but she isn't
out of the woods yet
or all the caves now nick stabs dina but
we see that she's wearing body armor
which is made up of books written by
robert lawrence
aka r.l stein who created the fear
street series
available in all good bookshops now
channeling sarah dina kills nick
and thus the curse is finally lifted for
the meantime but we'll talk about that
later on
now the pair make their way through the
tunnels and emerge inside nick's amazing
home
which is located at the same spot as
solomon's inside are several busts of
goats and rams
which are typically used as a sign of
satan there's also a picture that says
courage
almost inspiring nick to have the
courage he must in order to continue the
curse as well as the family tree
we see a literal picture of the family
tree that has solomon at the roots of it
with several of the goods springing
forth because of him we can also see two
black candles
and typically these were thought to be
instruments used by wizards and witches
outside we see the curse is clearly
lifted as immediately a car crash takes
place
and we hear that all is no longer good
in sunnyvale
nick's brother the mayor denies all
knowledge and i think that potentially
he could be the person who grabs the
book at the end
clearly the goods knew of the curse as
well as how to carry it out
i think that it will most likely be him
with sunnyvale falling apart it makes
sense that someone from there would
carry out the curse once more
and it becomes clear that dina and her
friends have a lot more trouble coming
down the line
this actually ties into the fear street
books themselves which told a multitude
of horror stories
featuring all kinds of demons they were
basically goosebumps for teens
and there may be other potentials such
as the queen of darkness
who we know that josh had been talking
to online though he knows who she is now
he could have potentially told her
everything and she might have went and
done the spell though
though i don't know if i'm reaching
there anyway everyone seemingly gets a
happy ending
and out in the woods dina and sam kiss
after rekindling their relationship
now could i hold my hands up yeah i have
no problem with that
but where i draw the line is burger king
the food tastes terrible yeah let the
dislikes come in but
i'm not having that yet i put my foot
down at burger king kfc all day baby
i'm a soldier and i report to the
colonel anyway amongst the moss and
where sarah was buried
they carved the first shady cider into
her grave and we cut to scenes of the
town
including them all before traveling
through it to see the book being picked
up
now that i've said it's probably the
mayor and maybe someone other than the
goods but looking at the hands they do
look like men's though i'm no hands
expert
i'm no hands expert yet now it is a
white dude though and good's brother has
the knowledge and mo to carry out the
curse
and they clearly set him up as a villain
in this so that's where i'd go for next
time
anyway that concludes the first vs3
trilogy i think it went out on a really
high note
other than the burger king now the first
two parts were great but part three is
where it really all came together for me
and you know what in the end i had a lot
of fun with it i hope you enjoyed the
video and again apologies for missing
part two
but hopefully this one has made it up
for you or
oh yeah even more videos anyway i'd love
to hear your comments below
and if you drop one as a thank you
you'll be entered into a competition on
the 30th of july
in which you could win an mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trilogy
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now
so message me at heavyspoilers on
twitter if that's you if you wants
emails to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of loki episode 6
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over the entire episode and
pointed out all the easter eggs we could
find
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for singing through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace